okay what's your name Caitlin Caitlin
Caitlin where you from Indiana
what part of India Melinda see how are
you been that way 15 years what got you
to come out here mmm my baby daddy
your baby daddy mm-hmm nice firm alia
see ya baby I have a 5 you're 5 kids so
where'd you sleep last night I say on
the sidewalk here early this morning
yeah I don't need sleep
you did it for you so of you your kids
are where they're worth family there
with your mom Sam yeah so
basically what you're tell me what your
drug of choice is down here Craig right
and how are you doing that I've been
doing Craig on and off since oh three
for our time
now you how do you how do you make money
however trusted then depending guys if
you pick up down here or what kind of
guys all kinds oh you had all kinds of
different guys yeah did we get danger
sometimes sometimes Jeffrey crazy
stories means just the basic those
stories took they're all the same
yeah how much money can you make
how much do I mean yeah I don't get that
but I made up to a thousand offer one
day down here before yeah but I mean
like on an average I made like three
about 300
do you holiday your kids how old are ya
I got it my oldest is 19 and my youngest
is line how you started earlier yeah
okay I'm ready meet you
the shelter is here oh [ __ ] no no I mean
I eat at restaurants yeah yeah in this
neighborhood yeah I mean most time I eat
junk food isn't some right so what you
got into drugs at what time high school
or don't like that I've been doing drugs
since I was nine nine years old really I
just have some pretty wild sisters how'd
you guess first get introduced to my
sisters
yeah
we start with pot yeah yeah and I mean
well my real mom like I was adopted from
my real mom she used to smoke we will
have me smoke weed with her because I
was too hyper
dispute you have it in control or is it
something that controls you know I
haven't i quit whenever i'm wondering
are you do it's not a ongoing change for
me yeah you smoke it
how many have you ever stopped several
times yeah nobody why do you choose to
go back move this last time I relapsed
because I went to a separation with my
husband
so you're divorced now or you're still
here I'm still married to what you know
we're cool we're best friends or
whatever but we're not together we've
been separated for a while
what advice would you give your case
prefer not to talk about that I keep my
kids in a reality I don't really like to
him we're [ __ ] with them about
anything so I don't think I really have
to give up high school they already know
they see it first thing they know your
situation down here yeah yeah talk you
talk to not in the past few years I it
I don't just because they're getting
well my two older ones I talked to more
now because they're 18 and 15 or 19 and
15 so they got more understanding or
whatever but my other children are
trying to add to age we're like if
you're not steady with that or whatever
then it can affect them in school and
different things so I kind of backed up
from them for a while until they get a
little bit older because I know that
like my lifestyle right now can't affect
them you know in a major way because
this is kind of like a a point for them
that you know directs their life so did
you ever think when you were young that
you didn't end up in this situation
don't want um uh-huh
where do you see yourself in five years
in ten years
definitely not doing this
I'm not sure
that's a question that you know I can't
answer I take every day as it comes
what are you most afraid of down here
down here yeah or just in your in your
hole where do you live where I live I
live down you live down here okay yeah
so that it makes a rough neighborhood is
it something but in the neighborhood
that scares you or just your future I
mean you can't forget into this or what
I'm not really scared people
I worried worried that something will
happen to my boyfriend my baby daddy
didn't I do like me I mean I just fit in
out of cars every day so I know that it
you know any point I can something can
happen Ben and that's just something
I've accepted with that
my biggest fear period in life though is
I don't like big cats lions tigers and
bears oh my
yeah what the craziest thing you've seen
happen down here if you're staying up
all night are you dear to you yeah I
mean a long time ago down here a girl
overdosed and my boyfriend had to just
like let her job she fell huh that was
pretty wild for me I don't like that
tiger it but she died and then I seen
some people jump a person in a
wheelchair
yeah that's kind of out for being like
that yeah you know it gets pretty rough
right there take care of yourself out
there the really nice talking to you
thank you for sure
[Music]